[Música]
genial
luego lo repetimos repetimos este rollo
que
nada
hola
esto lo cortan de la charla de youtube
vale esto piensas
esto empieza a contar los minutos y eso
ya
sí vale genial bien
e
vale se va a ir todo el texto
mi nombre es bibiana monje
alguien tiene el guión por ahí
a quién mola
este rollo
de no saber en el fondo si lo que estoy
viendo es del todo real o lo no es esa
cosa no de esto vamos a hablar
mi nombre es viviana monje y mi pasión
es el arte escénico digamos que lo
escénico para mí tiene que ver con la
propia vida esta puesta en escena
tridimensional de infinitas
posibilidades puro teatro
así que en realidad podría decir que mi
verdadera vocación es vivir
vayamos al título de esta charla el
error no existe ustedes qué piensan
más cara
donde hay algo imposible hay algo que
ignoro antes de empezar con esta charla
quiero aclarar una cosa y es que yo no
he venido aquí a decir ninguna verdad ya
no me creo ninguna verdad en el sentido
de que tampoco estoy del todo segura de
que eso exista la verdad pero como dice
mi amigo de hábitat estado sí me
gustaría compartir con ustedes algunas
posibles mentiras pero que a mí
particularmente me resultan súper útiles
bien no sé hasta qué punto son ustedes
conscientes o no de que la realidad en
la que viven es un producto directo de
su imaginación
los seres humanos somos creadores de
realidad por naturaleza
venimos a materializar lo invisible no
le suena esa frase que casi nadie
entiende pero que se dicen montón de lo
que es adentro es afuera
esta frase habla de esto nosotros de
momento de momento no tenemos la
capacidad para percibir las cosas tal
cual ocurren nosotros nos las inventamos
constantemente
pero básicamente por qué porque lo que
hemos venido a hacer aquí es a
experimentar la vida experimentar del
latín probar ensayar
cagarla vamos y venimos a hacerlo dentro
de un marco muy concreto limitado
condicionado lo llama mundo material o
tercera dimensión y en él hay algunas
limitaciones dentro de la percepción de
lo que está sucediendo a cada momento
para entendernos la realidad que
nosotros vemos es la punta del iceberg
de la realidad verdadera o sea la
metáfora ésta es la metáfora sus vidas
son la metáfora de esa creación que uno
hace internamente consciente o
inconscientemente esto me gustaría
aclararlo porque esta creación es
inevitable qué es lo que me interesa a
mí
si esto es inevitable lo estoy haciendo
yo lo que quiero es aprender a utilizar
este potencial infinito que todos
tenemos sin excepción y crear
realidad de la de una maravilla
como imposible para vivir en ella
tranquilos no tengo pensado traspasar
para de esta noche ni levantar butacas
de rollos de eso pero básicamente porque
tampoco le encuentro la utilidad no
sería muy espectacular porque para que
eso no quiere decir que no pueda
también tengo que confesarles que
todavía no he aprendido a hacerlo pero
donde hay algo imposible hay algo que
ignoro
vale bien
le ponemos el título el error no existe
hemos dicho que vivimos en una caja de
percepción limitada una especie de paz y
que cuando ocurre un suceso el que sea
cualquier cosa que nos pasa nuestra vida
lo primero que hacemos nosotros es
encuadrar lo de limitarlo enjuiciarlo a
inventarlo
esto es una no nos sirve para
nada esto es una maravilla esto es lo
que tiene que ser
qué bonito qué mal qué problema esto es
un grave error
entonces en vez de abrirlas en vez de
vivir las cosas abiertamente sin saber
lo que son porque si somos honestos nos
damos cuenta de que no tenemos ni idea
en ningún momento de lo que está pasado
casi nunca
en vez de vivirlo desde ahí lo que
hacemos es que lo vivimos como tal es
decir como hemos decretado en este caso
como un gravísimo error
y yo pensando ahora el dolor que hay
debajo de una realidad de este tipo
esta frase siempre improviso y luego se
me olvida lo que viene después
en realidad si somos honestos y miramos
observamos la naturaleza el universo la
vida nos damos cuenta de que el bien y
el mal no existen tampoco la moral es
una creación humana muy divertida en
alguno de los casos muy peligrosa pero
sobre todo útil como herramienta de
manipulación pero una estrella no es
buena o es mala un cataclismo no es
ético o no lo es la muerte de alguien no
es un castigo que llueva el día que vas
a la playa no es un error es una putada
porque te revienta al plano pero ah pero
hasta ahí
claro que si yo digo sean que pasa que a
mí me da
es que en el fondo a nosotros nos
conviene un huevo seguir creyendo en el
bien y el mal y les voy a decir por qué
pienso esto porque si yo elijo repito si
yo elijo
seguir creyendo en que las cosas están
bien o mal hechas en la dualidad en la
separación en el tú y en el yo en lo
blanco y lo negro como única opción en
creerme este mundo que otros se han
inventado para mí y me han impuesto si
yo sigo eligiendo todo eso y no me
arriesgo a descubrir entre paréntesis
inventar que para mí empieza a hacer lo
mismo
un paradigma totalmente nuevo y
desconocido
buscaron ya ahí porque yo no tendré que
salir de mi zona de confort por muy
cutre y dolorosa que ésta sea no y
tampoco tendré que enfrentarme con toda
esa que llevo intentando durante
años porque mira que tengo y mira
que van pasando en los años pero lo que
es mejor aún está para mí es la bomba es
que si sigo eligiendo no salir de ahí
podría tener todas las excusas que sigo
teniendo
para no asumir la responsabilidad
absoluta y total de mi experiencia cha
cha cha cha
y ustedes dicen y eso qué significa qué
significa eso no hacerme responsable
totalmente de mi experiencia pues para
mí tiene que ver con
hacerme responsable de cada cosa que
pasa en mi vida de cada cosa que siento
de cada cosa que pienso lo que digo de
lo que no digo de las personas que me
encuentro incluso si me apuran de los
eventos que ocurren en el planeta dejar
de crear una realidad en la que los
demás dios los gobiernos la vida o
bereber son los responsables de todas
mis desgracias o alegrías
pero la chiquita movida no porque decir
tú cómo se hace eso
así que quiero dejar una cosa clara
porque a veces en el discurso puede no
entenderse yo no estoy diciendo
evidentemente que esta postura o ésta
estoy compartiendo con ustedes sea mejor
o buena y la de quedarse en la zona de
confort va a ir nadando en kaká no lo
sea
yo estoy compartiendo mi elección porque
a mí me parece más interesante por si
les pudiera ser útil quiero dejar esto
claro porque de repente como un
contradiscurso extraño yo comparto esto
y también comparto una posible manera de
hacerlo
y el estado
manual de alta magia
primer paso
invéntate el segundo
y así hasta el final prueben
ensayen experimenten canela
como va a existir el error en una
realidad que no es real que sueño y que
además cabe lo inimaginable
para mí la cuestión es que decido o no
crear
en la magia antigua jamás ha existido
este concepto el del error siempre ha
habido aciertos o aprendizaje
en un universo en serio en un universo
donde lo único que existe es la magia
porque ya me dirán ustedes que es esto
como es posible que hayamos dejado de
creer en ella
cabe hasta eso
creadores creadoras
magath y magos
déjense de rollos porque un día se van a
morir
aunque eso tampoco exista y gocen sé
obscenamente esta maravilla teatral
muchísimas gracias a todos